[Music]
a new jersey man with plenty of down
time has found an uplifting way to spend
it
he realized many seniors are having
trouble maintaining their lawns and
yards during the pandemic
so he volunteered to take care of the
green around their homes
without accepting any green in return
nancy chen has the story
recently laid off from his job as vice
president of a new york city ad agency
brian schwartz has taken on what you
could call
a new grassroots campaign did you ever
mow lawns
as a kid never no
schwartz is picking up yard work mowing
trimming
reading and anything in between from
senior citizens
in northern new jersey for free i can
only imagine the stress
families are going through now and
especially now the last few months like
we all have been through a tough stretch
so i just i love grandparents
and i just want them to know they're not
alone
there's no fancy landscaping equipment
the new jersey native loads all his gear
in the family jeep
as he spruces up the community he grew
up in
he connects with his clients through a
website he set up i want to mow your
lawn
dot com lois reichert has lived in her
house for 70 years
and called shorts after finding him
online how important was it
for you to be able to find someone who
could do this oh my god it's
a lifesaver look at it i took such great
pride
in my yard and gardening and now
with you know pacemaker and a
defibrillator and
18 surgeries i just can't do it anymore
and that's heartbreaking the digital
advertising manager started the site
just days after getting laid off in
mid-june with bills mounting
a mortgage waiting and yet another life
change ahead
i just wanted to do good got out there
just didn't want to sit around you know
my newborn
first newborn just came mid july and you
know i knew i was going to have a little
bit of down time
so now just getting back into the swing
of things down time in a newborn i don't
think i've ever heard that before i know
what sleep means right now
[Music]
schwartz has a handful of clients so far
the difficulty for many elderly
homeowners
lies in tracking down someone to trust
it means the world to me to have
somebody
that can help me because it's very hard
to get anybody to help you
especially if you're a senior you get a
lot of people that take advantage of you
or do something but don't finish it
alfred byer reached out to schwartz
after struggling with
carpal tunnel and back pain when was the
last time you were able to mow your lawn
quite a while ago the last time i cut
the top of the bushes because the
neighbors complained he said this guy is
too lazy to cut the bush
so i forced myself to cut the tap in
front of the bushes
as word has gotten out a backlog is
beginning to build
with more requests for help coming in
but so too have calls
offering help as volunteers similar boat
as me recently laid off as a result of
the pandemic there's millions of us out
there
so i feel like i'm not the only one that
is kind of in the same boat that has the
equipment to help out
in the meantime short says he's still
actively looking for a full-time job
and wants to see where the site can go
but hopes to continue volunteering
i'm not going to stop by any means i'm
still going to keep it going i'm going
to communicate
with whoever brings on an offer that you
know i'm
going to still want to help out a couple
hours a week just a few more lawns
for a cut above for cbs this morning
saturday
nancy chen east rutherford new jersey